j'ai grandi dans la forêt d'orléans a
toujours été présent dans ma vie et
c'est vrai que j'ai toujours eu cette
passion fin cet amour de le sentir de
travailler ce matin là victor valdés a
choisi de travailler dufresne il aime
les voix de notre région et il a déjà en
tête ce qu'il va en faire sa fête un bol
c'est un bol enfin un gros bol sûrement
à 24 ans ainsi ap de marketer sculpteur
est tourneur sur bois
il s'est mis à son compte pour créer des
objets dans cette matière qu'il aime
tant l'odeur enfin c'est une odeur quand
même qui est très agréable
le toucher c'est une main matériaux
chauds c'est un matériau enfin
formidable et puis on peut on peut tout
faire et one victor balès réalise les
pistes d'un seul bloc sans collage c'est
le morceau de bois qui va donner la
forme de l'objet
je viens façonner la pièce c'est un peu
comme un gros taille crayon j'ai mon
outil ma gauche qui coupent et je viens
tranché la matière avec la pièce qui
tourne
peu à peu le vol prend forme guidée par
la main de l'artisan
ensuite il faut creuser l'internet ont
recherché le fond et obtenir une paroi
les plus régulières un peu de ponçage le
tour est joué
le bol terminée enfin pas tout à fait il
reste à appliquer un peu d'huile pour
protéger le bois et faire durer cet
ustensile de la vie quotidienne j'adore
faire des objets qui après vont avoir
une vive on voit là vont servir donc là
la vaisselle on est maintenant 1
c'est un objet qui sert tous les jours
trois fois par jour donc je suis à la
partie dans des objets qui servent
joindre l'utile à l'agréable c'est comme
ça que notre artisan définit son travail
assiettes plats ou luminaires des pièces
uniques qu'il peut réaliser sur commande
au
[Musique]